es ist ein ganz ganz schlimmer tag für
meine heimatstadt riga und auch für uns
im land rheinland pfalz und natürlich
sind unsere gedanken und trauer erstmal
bei den ganzen angehörigen die jetzt
tote zu beklagen haben deren leben von
einer sekunde auf die andere ausgelöscht
worden ist so eine brutale tat und
darunter auch ein baby war es wirklich
so schlimm ist die vorstellung dass
eltern den tod ihres kindes betrauern
müssen
es ist einfach nur furchtbar und wir
können jetzt heute nur sagen dass wir
mit unseren gedanken bei ihnen sind und
dass wir natürlich auch bei den opfern
sind bei den schwerverletzten und für
sie hoffen für sie beten dass sie das
überleben und das sie diesen
schreckenstag einfach dass sie gesunden
möglichst bald wieder ansonsten der
innenminister hat es gesagt wir waren
natürlich bei den ganzen rettungskräften
bei der polizei haben uns bedankt und
man kann nur sagen dass alles sehr sehr
schnell und sehr sehr gut miteinander
gearbeitet haben
auch in so einer schweren lage das muss
man sich einfach vorstellen was es für
junge oder auch ältere helfer und
helferinnen bedeutet in so einer lage
zum einsatz zu kommen
auch das ist eine ganz große
schreckliche herausforderung aber die
hilfskräfte aus stadt und land haben
sehr sehr eng zusammengearbeitet man
sehr schnell vor ort und auch die
betreuung der betroffenen menschen und
der angehörigen ist sofort angelaufen
auch unser eigener opferbeauftragte wenn
ich das noch sagen darf der des landes
ist schon in kontakt auch bei ihm steht
das telefon nicht still es ist jetzt an
allererster stelle
dass die menschen die unter diesem
trauma jetzt stehen dass man in hilfe
anbietet auch über den polizeiseelsorger
in die polizei rhein um diesen
schrecklichen tag für sich arbeiten zu
können
das allerschlimmste ist heute dass
menschen ihr leben verloren haben durch
diese grausame tat und dass dieser tag
wirklich ein schlimmer schrecklicher tag
für die angehörigen ist die ja mitten an
einem ganz normalen tag um 13 uhr 50
oder so ähnlich
ihr leben gelassen haben komplett aus
dem leben gerissen worden sind das ist
einfach sehr sehr schlimm für uns alle
vielleicht darf ich noch ergänzen
neben all der trauer hat unsere polizei
sehr schnell und sehr beherzt
eingegriffen wir hatten sehr schnell
eine hohe anzahl an polizeikräften hier
zusammen gezogen aus der stadt aus der
umgebung spezialkräfte die bundespolizei
unterstützt die wasserschutzpolizei im
einsatz gab um die sicherheit unserer
mitbürgerin mitbürger zu gewährleisten
weil man zu einem zu frühen zeitpunkt
natürlich mit allem rechnen muss und von
dem her dass es dann wenigstens eine
gute situation dass die sicherheit sehr
schnell hergestellt war und natürlich
die vielen vielen rettungskräfte die
zusammengezogen wurden und jetzt müssen
wir auch irgendwann die betreuen das
läuft jetzt schon an die bilder gehen
keine maus den kopf das geht zu herzen
dass das nimmt hier alle mit dieser
vorstellung
wir können ihn im moment glaube ich
nicht mehr sagen das müssen sie
verstehen die dinge laufen jetzt alle
ihren ermittlungs weg und die polizei
wird die ganze nacht vor ort sein und
wird natürlich ermitteln das ist ein
sehr langer radweg diejenigen petri
erkennen können dass beurteilen und das
muss natürlich meter für meter
untersucht werden
und das sind jetzt die nächsten aufgaben
die anstehen und weitere informationen
sie haben es ja angekündigt bekommen es
gibt presseinformationen da stehen wir
ihnen dann auch wieder zur verfügung
lassen sie uns noch mal genau hinschauen
wir wollen auch keine falschen
informationen abgeben jetzt aber wir
werden sie informieren
die ermittlungen sind am anfang wir
haben keinerlei die ermittlungen sind am
anfang wir haben noch keinerlei
erkenntnisse zur motivlage
die befragung des tatverdächtigen läuft
im moment da kann ich noch nichts dazu
sagen
ja das sollten sie jetzt den profis
überlassen der polizei der
staatsanwaltschaft und die müssen jetzt
ihre aufgaben machen
danach einfach mal eine vier tage deren
rat wird
also ich bin da auf jeden fall dabei
sein
wir werden auch da das wahrscheinlich
weitestgehend wiederholen müssen die
ermittlungen müssen sauber und
sorgfältig geführt werden und gerüchte
nutzen uns in einer solchen situation
überhaupt nichts also das ist nicht bös
gemeint aber sie verstehen dass nach dem
gegenwärtigen raketen stand ist ein
fahrzeug aus richtung basilika in die
konstantinstraße eingefahren
mit einer person besetzt und ist von
dort dann nach rechts in die
fußgängerzone in die brot straße
eingebogen und über den hauptmarkt
weiter hier bisher zur porta nigra und
dann nach rechts in die christophstraße
abgebogen und dort dann etwa 200
mitarbeiter dann durch kräfte der
polizei trier gestellt worden der täter
ist festgenommen worden
und nach unserem kenntnisstand hat das
fahrzeug auf den weg über die benannten
straßen wahllos personen angefahren und
überfahren
dabei kam es zu einer großen anzahl von
verletzten
nach unserem gegenwärtigen kenntnisstand
befand sich die person alleine im
fahrzeug darüber hinaus ob es noch
weitere personen gibt ist uns nicht
bekannt dass läuft die ermittlungen dazu
sind voll im gange bei der person
handelt es sich um einen 51-jährigen
mann hier aus der region wie herr
minister bereits sagte können wir dazu
noch keine auskunft geben weil wir erst
gesicherte zahlen haben bevor wir dazu
etwas sagen das wird dann
voraussichtlich in der pressekonferenz
um 19 uhr sachen wir haben keinerlei
erkenntnisse zur motivlage sehr schnell
also direkt wir wurden ja direkt
alarmiert über das lagezentrum als klar
war dass die polizei auch gerufen worden
ist also sehr sehr schnell
ich war ganz in der nähe
wir haben uns dann auf gemachten
absprache broker lebens und ich dass wir
dann vor ort muss ja erst mal geholfen
werden und die einsätze sind koordiniert
worden und so dass wir uns dann
verabredet haben im polizeipräsidium uns
einen überblick über die lage zu machen
und danach sind wir dann zu den zu der
stelle wo die angehörigen und die
geschädigten von andere anlaufstelle
haben ja und waren im dom und gibt es
eine stelle fragen wieso wir dann diese
distanzen
das ergebnis hier gibt es am theater
nach meiner kenntnis
das wird aber auch alles jetzt bekannt
gegeben ist teilweise schon
veröffentlicht wir haben diese
anlaufstellen für angehörige für
menschen die in dem bereich wohnen und
natürlich auch durchaus traumatisiert
sein können dass in der nachbarschaft
das sind ja schreckliche bilder und
schreckliche ereignisse die auf 1 1
stürmen
das haben wir professionell organisiert
mit den rettungsdienst organisationen
und natürlich werden auch die ersten die
an den ort der taten gewesen sind auch
betreut polizei ein seelsorger
psychologen die zah
[Musik]
diese aufgepasst ja es ist ein sehr
schlimmer tag größe unserer meiner
heimatstadt ihre für unser ganzes land
wir sind natürlich vor allem in unseren
gedanken bei den angehörigen sind
menschen von einer sekunde auf die
nächste herausgerissen worden aus ihrem
leben getötet worden durch diese erst
wenige tat und darunter auch ein kleines
kindern baby und das ist einfach alles
sehr sehr schlimm und ich kann nur sagen
dass wir mit unserem gesang bei den
anderen sind und dass wir auch bei denen
sind die jetzt schwer verletzt im
krankenhaus liegen und dass wir an sie
denken dass wir für sie beten dass sie
gesund wieder zurück kommen aus dem
krankenhaus
dezember zu beginnen und so auch bei der
polizei und bei den rettungskräften
bedankt und polizei hat berichtet vier
minuten nach erster hinweis konnte
vermutliche täter festgenommen werden
das zeigt wie schnell gehandelt werden
konnte und wie dann doch vielleicht
weitere schlimme dinge verhindert werden
konnten
das ist dann vielleicht auch noch mal
richtig zu sagen dass das ganze
rettungswesen hier wirklich unglaublich
gut funktioniert hat und wirklich alle
organisationen aus stadt und land sehr
eng miteinander kooperiert haben und
damit auch sehr schnell vor ort waren
polizei ohnehin aber natürlich auch all
diejenigen geholfen haben und helfen
jetzt auch noch in dieser schrecklichen
lage
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren